los neerlandeses consideran absurdo el
nuevo toque de quedar nacional impuesto
por el gobierno como medida para
combatir las nuevas variantes del coi 19
muchos salieron a las calles a
manifestar en contra de la nueva
restricción que empezó en la noche del
sábado nadie podrá salir a la calle
entre las nueve de la noche y las cuatro
y treinta de la madrugada
sólo están permitidos los
desplazamientos en esa franja en casos
excepcionales por motivos laborales o si
la persona está a cargo del cuidado de
otros
[Música]
y explicarle esto a los niños de 89 años
tengo que decirles no primero
esperaremos la mutación británica la
mutación sudafricana y la mutación
brasileña o hay que decirles que tampoco
lo entiendes no se ofrece ninguna
perspectiva en lo absoluto o si esto va
a tomar mucho tiempo ahora son datos
soul and house los medios no siempre
muestran las protestas en rechazo de las
medidas contra el coronavirus de manera
amable espero que podamos demostrar que
esto es sólo una voz una voz que dice no
tenemos mucho miedo de ir en la
dirección equivocada
el jueves la mayoría de los legisladores
neerlandeses respaldó el toque de queda
planeado por el gobierno a pesar de las
duras críticas de algunos miembros de la
oposición así como muchos ciudadanos
ellos denunciaron igualmente la medida
como una restricción excesiva de las
libertades en la ciudad de jaén joven
también se registraron disturbios la
policía dispersó a la multitud con gases
lacrimógenos el 'toque de queda'
nacional irá hasta el 9 de febrero
inicialmente y la multa por
incumplimiento asciende
115 dólares además países bajos prohibió
los vuelos desde reino unido sudáfrica y
américa del sur y ahora exige pruebas
pcr negativas para cualquier persona que
entra al país